So we've got to talk today about some tweets
that have surfaced from congresswoman Elon,
Omar and Roshita to leap where they appeared
to also be calling for the deportation of
American citizens, something that Donald Trump
has heavily and correctly criticized for over
the last 10 days. So let me set this back
up for you from the beginning.
Donald Trump tweeted back on July 14th. It's
been 10 days now since the started quote.
So interesting to see Progressive Democrat
Congress women who originally came from countries
whose governments are a complete and total
catastrophe, the worst, most corrupt and inept
anywhere in the world. If they even have a
functioning government at all now loudly and
viciously telling the people of the United
States the greatest and most powerful nation
on earth, how our government is to be run,
why don't they go back and help fix the totally
broken and crime infested places from which
they came. Then come back and show us how
it is done. These places need your help badly.
You can't leave fast enough. I'm sure that
Nancy Pelosi would be very happy to quickly
work out free travel arrangements. And this
was followed by a chat at a Donald Trump rally
in North Carolina about a week ago or so,
where at the mere mention of Alano Mar by
Donald Trump, the crowd started chanting,
send her back, send her back.
[inaudible] lied. You talked about the evil
Israel.
So this is undeniably xenophobic. It's disgusting.
It's anti-American. The president of the United
States suggesting that not only legal American
citizens, but also just legally elected officials
who are members of the House of Representatives
be uh, sent back or leave and go back to their
quote original countries. It's absolutely
and totally disgusting. It's also counter
to the idea that Donald Trump has espoused
for years, that if you don't like what's going
on in the United States, then you should work
to change it. I mean, all of Obama's presidency,
Donald Trump's perspective was, I don't like
what's happening in the country as a result
of Barack Obama. I want it to change and eventually
I want it to change by running for president.
Uh, if members of Congress want to change
the country for the better as they see it,
Trump says they should leave and go back to
their quote. Original countries. Donald Trump's
entire campaign was based on not leaving and
going somewhere else.
Maybe Germany where Trump's family came from,
but I'm trying to improve the country that
you live in. So anyway, total hypocrisy. Um,
now we get to this, uh, latest, uh, a revelation,
which is that it starts to get a little complicated
because at least two members of the so-called
squad, these four ethnic minority, congresswoman,
uh, congresswoman Rashida to leave and congresswoman
Elon Omar are on record as appearing to suggest
the deportation of people that they don't
like. Now I received probably 50 or 60 emails
in the last 12 hours. Some from the right
saying, David, you are a fill for the left
and you will not cover that. Atlanta, Omar
and Rashida to leave have also tweeted about
deporting people that are legally here in
the United States. I received s roughly half
of those 50 or 60 emails were from people
on the left who said, David, you don't need
to cover this because it's a non-story and
the tweets by Alano Omar and Rashida to leave
are completely different than what Donald
Trump has said and done.
Well, I'm going to cover it likely to the
displeasure of everybody who listens or watches
because it does deserve coverage. But it is
also true that these comments from the Congress,
women, the now Congress women, which is an
important thing to mention, are not the same
as what Donald Trump said. So let's look first
at Illinois. Omar. Back in October of 2012
a Twitter user posted an article about a Maine
mayor, a mayor in the state of Maine saying
that Somalis should leave their culture at
the door in the United States. A Twitter battle
developed Elana Mar took the position that
Somalis don't need to leave their culture
at the door, that America is a melting pot
and then eventually Ilana March tweeted, quote,
we are citizens and can't be deported. Why
don't we deport you to wherever you came from?
Now, I have to tell you, this does not seem
to me to be Alon Omar suggesting that citizens
be deported.
I see this as Alon Omar saying that deporting
her as a Somali born, but now American citizen
is no more logical than than deporting any
of the u s citizens that are arguing with
Alana Mar on Twitter about how Somalis should
leave their culture at the door. I don't see
this as the same as go back to your country,
your original country or whatever. I see this
more as it's absurd to be telling anyone,
me or you to go back to your country now.
This is not a defense of Elon. Omar reflexively,
as many of you know and have criticized me
for, uh, I don't agree with, uh, many of Ilana
Mars sort of approaches to politics and even
some of our political positions. She's very
much for the bds movement to boycott Israel.
I'm against that movement. I've explained
why it's not the topic of today's program.
I have no incentive to reflectively defend
Elana Omar if she doesn't deserve defending.
I just don't think this is the same as what
Donald Trump said. And more importantly, she
was not president of the United States when
she tweeted that, nor was she even a member
of Congress. So I believe I forget the date
now on that tweet. Then we get to Rashita
to leap who back in December of 2015 tweeted
about Donald Trump, deport this a whole. Now
this one is not so easily defensible. This
is pretty direct and clear. The only real
difference is that Rashida to leave in 2015
was a member of the Michigan House of Representatives,
not a member of Congress and not a president
of the United States. Now. I still disagree
with what she said as I disagree with what
Donald Trump said, but if republicans are
going to take the position that when Trump
said it, it was merely symbolic and met to
say they disagree that he disagrees with the
policies of the squad.
If they are going to take the position that
when Trump's followers chanted send her back.
It was merely symbolic. A way to say we disagree
with the politics of Ilana Omar. Then I don't
know how you can't also a a sort of be forced
logically into accepting that when Rashida
to leave is saying deport this a whole. It
is the same type of symbolism that is I disagree
with this person's politics and I don't think
he's good for the country. I don't like this
stuff. I don't like any of it, but the truth
is that what Alon Omar said is not the same
as what Donald Trump said. What Rashida to
leave set is actually closer to what Donald
Trump said. But again, if we are saying that
these are symbolic political statements, we
have to apply that to Rashid a to leave statement
as well. Otherwise we are hypocrites, which
I know doesn't matter to the right anymore.
Uh, but it matters to me. So I talked about
it. I don't know how many people uh, will
agree with my perspective here that these
are comments worthy of commentary, but there
is a distinction between them and what Donald
Trump has been saying. I want to hear from
you. Make sure if you're watching this clip
on youtube that you are subscribed to our
channel, hit the subscribe button. We are
now beyond 702,000 subscribers. If you are
listening on the radio or watching on TV or
whatever, uh, you can either find this clip
on youtube and comment on it or tweet me at
[inaudible].